[Music]
hello I'm Gregory Sadler and this is the
beginning of a new series of videos
which I'm going to be shooting each of
which should be about 25 to 35 minutes
long that are gonna be focused on
Hegel's phenomenology of spirit we're
going to go through the entirety of this
work passage by passage by passage I'm
trying to to not skip any of the
portions of it even the portions that
seem almost indecipherable we're going
to dig into them and make sense of them
this is for me a sort of new experiment
I've done a lot of video lectures as
some of you may know I've put together a
number of courses ranging from
existentialism to intro to philosophy to
ethics to religion in America and I'm
constantly bringing up new material but
I've been asked for a long time when are
you gonna do Hegel that may sound like a
strange thing but I suppose YouTube
viewers of philosophical videos are an
unusual Bunch
and so people have been asking for this
for quite a while I've shot a few videos
on Hegel in in my intro classes strange
enough place to do that I think some
people would see that as a a recipe for
disaster given how dense and difficult
Hegel is but nonetheless that's that's
what I did he is one of my my favorite
philosophers and this is really one of
my favorite books of all time of
philosophy I rate him up there with
Plato and Aristotle Augustine and some
Descartes we could go down the list of
top-notch philosophers and Hegel is
among them so what I'm going to be doing
with this is rather experimental I'm not
sure how long it's going to take me how
many videos it will require but what I'm
going to do is go through each one of
the
the sections and there are total when we
get to the very end
there are 808 sections so each of them
is you know a paragraph or sometimes a
page worth of writing we're going to go
through each one of those I'm going to
read it and then I'm going to comment on
it and the commentary maybe explaining
what's going on in the passage maybe
making sure that we we don't miss the
references from that passage to earlier
passages that we've already covered and
maybe talking about the historical
context because Hegel doesn't do a lot
of naming of names in in this book which
is different than some of his other
works so there's there's a lot of
different possibilities I'm gonna be
switching back and forth you're gonna
see me sitting here reading the passage
to you hopefully I'll have text up on
the screen along with me and then I'll
be shooting in front of a chalkboard for
the what would be the lecture portion of
this and I've been thinking about this
for quite a while what exactly I wanted
to do and what would be the best format
for for doing something like this on
Hegel specifically because it is such a
complex thinker not only by temperament
but by design he thinks that that is
integral to to the practice of
philosophy he says he understands it so
what I'm doing here is not really
teaching a class per se because we don't
have the back and forth student
interaction of course we do have the
comments section which people are
welcome to leave comments and when
people ask questions I'll try to respond
as best as I can to them sometimes they
may be actually directing people well go
back and take a look at this this
section of this video I think you could
look at this as something like the core
for a self-directed study if Hegel is
somebody who you've always wanted to
understand and he is well worth
understand
because he really does in many respects
set the agenda or at least part of the
agenda for the whole of 19th century and
a lot of 20th century philosophy he is
somebody who if you want to get a good
education and philosophy or even in the
humanities or the history of ideas in
general you need to grapple with at one
point or another so if you're if you're
interested in doing a kind of
self-directed study this could be the
core for that perhaps by the time that
we're finished with this this will have
generated some sort of community and
inquiry around which we can design some
other projects I'm not sure this is all
very like I said experimental we're
gonna see what happens with this and I'm
just going to keep producing them and
what happens with them I suppose depends
in part on the viewership so like I said
what we're gonna do is it's going to go
back and forth from text to commentary
I'm going to be providing the commentary
I do have some some secondary sources
who I particularly like but I'm gonna
try to minimize my references to them
but I thought it would be good to
mention them right off the bat
two of them are these these classic
French commentators on Hegel Alexander
Khrushchev and John if elite George AB
influenced a lot of the French thought
unusual yet believed it as well but hip
elite is koja you could think of as a
lot of fireworks and very interesting
play of ideas hip elite is a bit more of
a careful scholarly attitude and
approach towards it there are other
thinkers who I particularly enjoy
reading on Hegel and they would include
you know Stan Lee Rosen for example
Adrian pepper Zac who also writes a lot
on levy Nast on Christian philosophy
Heidegger Martin Heidegger has
unfortunately only discusses certain
parts of the phenomenology but I'm going
to bring these things in very
infrequently because I don't want
us to try to turn into a you know web of
erudition I really want to focus on
Hegel's own text as as such and I think
it's important to point out this is one
of several different translations that
are available in English there's another
one that you'll see translated as the
phenomenology of mind I may on occasion
if I think that the translation in some
of the passages of this bring up them if
I think that the translation is a little
bit more felicitous you know a little
bit closer to what we want I may bring
them up but but I'm not going to to
guarantee that we're going to be using
this in part because this is a decent
translation and it's readily available
so if you want to get yourself a copy of
this if you're going to follow along
with this entire course I say I think
that's a good idea so without any
further ado we're gonna start moving now
into the very first part of the
phenomenology the preface and we'll
start with the very first section
it is customary to practice a work with
an explanation of the author's aim why
he wrote the book and the relationship
in which he believes it's a stand to
other earlier or contemporary treatises
on the same subject in the case of a
philosophical work however such an
explanation seems not only superfluous
but in view of the nature of the subject
matter even inappropriate and misleading
for whatever might appropriately be said
about philosophy and a preface say a
historical statement of the main drift
and point of view the general content
and results a string of random
assertions and assurances about truth
none of this can be accepted as the way
in which to expound philosophical truth
also since philosophy moves essentially
in the element of universality which
includes within itself the particular it
might seem that here more than in any of
the other sciences the subject matter
itself and even its complete nature were
expressed in the aim and the final
results the execution being by contrast
really the UH nacelle on the other hand
in the ordinary view of anatomy for
instance say the knowledge of the parts
of the body regarded is inanimate we are
quite sure that we do not as yet possess
the subject matter itself the content of
this science but must in addition exert
ourselves to know the particulars
further in the case of such an aggregate
of information which has no right to
bear the name of science an opening talk
about aim and other such generalities is
usually conducted in the same historical
an uncomprehending way in which the
contents itself these nerves muscles etc
is spoken of in the case of philosophy
on the other hand this would give rise
to the incongruity that along with the
employment of such a method its
inability to grasp the truth would also
be demonstrated
this first paragraph in the
phenomenology is quite famous for
Hegel's insistence that really you can't
write a preface as the first thing that
he's saying writing his preface so a lot
of people have played around with this
and and you know dari dad for example
made a lot of hay out of this and
talking about the impossibility Hegel's
own position but Hegel really is earnest
about this what you're gonna find is
that he he can be quite sardonic he can
be quite ironic he can he can make a lot
of very biting comments withering
sometimes throughout this preface
because he's he's looking at other
philosophical approaches of his own time
and showing where they're wanting
showing where they've fallen short
showing where they thought they got it
right but actually only partly got it
right and in thinking that they got the
hold of it right got it wrong and this
is something that actually if you take
away Hegel from it and take away his own
particular way of doing philosophy I
think that quite a bit in this very
first part of the prophets would
actually still make what a good bit of
sense when we're thinking about how
philosophy differs from other
disciplines let alone differs from other
genres of literature so he starts out
you know wondering can you actually
write a preface to a philosophical work
now what does that mean
we're talking about a work that in some
way is going beyond the sorts of things
that we're normally looking at you know
a work of philosophy for example cannot
be what we used to call a coffee table
book you know those nicely illustrated
large books that you sit on the coffee
table why do we call them a coffee table
book because they're they're kind of
books that somebody would sit in a
coffee table and while they're sipping
some coffee maybe you know killings
time they could page through
philosophical works are not like that
you have to apply yourself to them
because somebody else in writing them
applied themselves they work in the
medium of complex and articulate
thoughts at least that's if they're good
philosophies they're just you know
regurgitated dogmatic statements that's
not really philosophy in the sense that
that Hegel is talking about so cannot a
a a practice can some sort of here's
what what is going on here's what to
expect can that sort of thing that's
sort of warning that sort of
advertisement be be effectively written
for philosophy Hegel says no it's
actually inappropriate and misleading
and you know this should give us some
pause because he like I said he himself
is writing a preface and philosophical
works generally have a preface a
foreword an introduction oftentimes
they're not even by the person who wrote
them they're by some somebody else who's
connected with them or famous and you
get them to write the piece so what is
Hegel actually driving it why does he
say this he says whatever we might
appropriately say about philosophy in a
preface is not going to work what are
the sorts of things that we usually say
in a preface Hegel he uses this term
historical and he doesn't just mean in
the sense of history books or history
courses or history as a discipline he's
using this in a broader sense to mean
something like a narrative you know if
you look at a lot of books prophecies
you see things like I never would have
written this book except for having go
onto this conference and then having got
a grant from this this institution or
agency and then this person got me
thinking about that and all of those
things are
other contingents their their accidental
they could be faithfully accidental to
use the the great skeptic and
hermeneutic scholar aroma cards phrase
but their contingent there's no internal
necessity in them if you were to ask
somebody well why'd you write this book
they could say well let me tell you this
story about how the book out written and
that's that's all fine for radio
interviews and for meet the author sort
of things but when we want to know why
did you write this book of philosophy we
don't want to hear Hegel things we don't
want to hear well you know I had I think
I had a book in me that needed to get
out or I had these experiences and it
can't be reflecting we want to hear
something more general something that's
not so contingent something that is in
certain respect more Universal so what
else do we often find in preferences
let's call them generalities pits yeah
bolts the good words to use a certain
way of parroting this well oftentimes
you'll you'll see them you know engaging
they'll say in this book you know I'm
really concerned with the development of
religion in the last two centuries in
America and here's the things I was
really interested in obviously I'm going
to do more of this in the work itself
but really big picture here is what I'm
about
well that's pretty general notice that's
not Universal in any sort of
philosophical sense it's just kind of
general and it doesn't tell you much of
anything so for a philosophical work
what would you say you know think about
Plato's dialogues if they had a prop
let's see he had a preface to the
Republic it would run something like
this well you know these people got
together Socrates is going down to the
Piraeus there's so there's the
historical part and then he gotta roped
into a conversation that they wouldn't
let him out unfortunately there happen
to be this this firebrand through semuc
is there some more contingent stuff and
then they started talking about justice
and justice is a topic that's very
important to all of us and we should all
be highly concerned with it now there
are different theories of justice
available and this book will discuss
some of them we might summarize them as
might makes right or egoism or virtue
ethics and you notice either throwing
around terms and they're saying here's
what we're gonna do in this book but
they're not actually doing it
they're just referencing it they're just
generalizing about what's going on
they're not actually giving you any of
the meat and you might say well it's a
preface what do you expect but he --gel
is saying look a work that's going to be
philosophical he has to have a
philosophical preface as well that's why
it's so hard so then he says you know
philosophy it moves essentially in the
in the the element of universality and
he says universality includes within
itself the particular now this is
something that's that's very important
the in terms of Hegel's own
philosophical approach and I want to
stress this at the beginning because
this is going to come up over and over
again so philosophy
so really what we need to do is not just
contrast the universality with the
particular but I'll put two particulars
down there and why am i putting two
particulars down here to signify that
what we're dealing with is is a whole
range of particulars that are supposed
to somehow come under the rubric of the
universal this this is what allows us
this provides us with intelligibility
this is what we actually experience and
there is I'm going to use this word an
awful lot because it's a central part of
Hegel's idea there's a dialectic there
is a back-and-forth relationship between
the universal that allows us to
understand things and the particulars
which is what we actually experience
both of them require each other
no no particular is no universal no
universal no particulars is such just
you know an amorphous massive as James
called it booming buzzing confusion you
need both of these philosophy is
particularly connected with universality
it's aimed at trying to figure out what
are the universals and what can we know
about them and how are they connected to
them and and are them you know are they
connected to each other in such a way
that perhaps one is a universal of
universals these are the sorts of things
that philosophy has to be concerned with
according to Hegel so he says it might
seem that that here more than in the
other sciences and when we see this word
science this is another thing I should
probably say philosophy is one of the
sciences is also science as such the
science of Sciences for Hegel and the
German word for this
is this an shaft and when you think
about science in an American or Anglo
American setting the word is a bit
deceptive for us when I'm reading Hegel
because we tend to associate science
with what are properly called the
natural sciences as opposed to the
social or human sciences the guy's
vision shaft and in German or the CIC
men in French so there's this tendency
to pull up science a little bit short
the other thing that you got to remember
about this and this is a historical
point something from the history of
ideas is that the term science and its
narrowing occurred in late modernity so
much of what they were willing to call
science at the time people would talk
about history as being a science they
would talk about not just economics the
dismal science but psychology and even
philosophical psychology as being a
science so all of that fits under this
so philosophy is supposed to be
scientific and he says even it's
complete nature we're expressing the aim
and final results the execution would be
the the UH nacelle factor so if a
preface is supposed to again be truly
philosophical and philosophy is a matter
of science then it should be just sort
of reporting here's what I actually
found out here's what I'm proving here's
what I'm here's the case I'm making here
is what we've attained those were the
results and then he says no wait a
second if we were to look at another
science one of the ones that was growing
by the way at that time Anatomy says the
ordinary view of Anatomy parts of the
body are looked at as things that we
have knowledge of and if we only know
the universal but we don't know the
particulars that we don't say that we've
actually got the science we know some of
the general principles you know here
would be a great example
why isn't Wikipedia a substitute or any
other encyclopedia for that matter
why isn't that a substitute for actually
taking classes on a subject because in
the classes you don't just learn
information about particulars you
actually grapple with particulars and
thereby see how the universal plays out
in relation to particulate it's one
thing to have a book sense of you know
universals it's another thing to
actually apply it in real concrete cases
and see how messy it gets and see how
you have to sort of re understand the
the universal principles or approach in
this case you have to acquire you know
some some judgement about it and that's
part of acquiring knowledge so we
wouldn't think that somebody who just
knew the the general principles of
Anatomy actually understood Anatomy the
reader would say that they possess the
subject matter itself they have to get
to know the particulars in the case of
Anatomy probably you need to do some
dissections or at least you know trace
hook the muscles and bones why so if
philosophies like that what does that
mean for philosophy here's a good
question to ask yourself could you read
just the phenomenology and not have to
engage the rest of the great works in
philosophy
I think Hegel would actually say no why
because if you actually want to grasp
what he's talking about in all these
dialectical shifts and changes you would
want to know something at least about
some of the works that he's grappling
and the developments that are taking
place
so he says in the case of an aggregate
of information which has no right to
bear the name science an opening talk
about aim and other generalities is
usually calm is usually carried out in
this sort of historical way here's what
we've usually been up to and here's the
contingent things that were interested
in in the case of philosophy this would
mean that there would be an incongruity
there would be a disconnect and what
that would produce is a a non
philosophical and what that would amount
to is an anti philosophical way of
approaching philosophy itself I see this
happen quite often in the way that that
philosophy gets taught I've been guilty
of that myself that sometimes sometimes
in trying to oversimplify we we lose the
spirit of what it is that we're doing in
philosophy the philosophy really is the
sort of thing that Hegel makes it out to
be where it's this totalizing discipline
that really makes sense out of
everything could we really have an intro
to philosophy text that would be
adequate to that that aim to that scope
probably not be very difficult to design
it so that's why Hegel can't write the
preface which is about your right